[Music]
[Applause]
before we get to chris sims paulie has a
question well
i heard a lot of hubbub about 20 minutes
ago from the back row and mcglovin says
i have a whose career would you want i
think it's quarterback related and he's
very frightened oh all right what do you
have okay at first blush you're gonna be
like well this is obvious but whose
career would you want
washington football quarterback ryan
fitzpatrick or
former broncos bears dolphins
quarterback jay cutler and one of the
reasons i asked they have almost
identical stats
uh 223 touchdowns for fitzpatrick 227
for cutler
35 000 yards for cutler 35 000 yards for
fitzpatrick fitzpatrick's entering his
17th season cutler played 12 seasons
before retiring all right
well let me start there with chris sims
chris whose career would you rather have
ryan fitzpatrick's or jay cutler
well
i man it is that's a tough one i mean
you know i guess i come let me just go
through this with my thought a little
bit you know cutler
had certainly more high-end talent and
did bring a team to an nfc championship
game there's no doubt about that but i
guess i'd also look at it and go damn
i'm better than what my career ended up
really being maybe i should have had
more success
so i i think you know i don't know
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with ryan
fitzpatrick i am i'm gonna it's a close
one there but i'll go with fitzpatrick
you know i just give him a lot of credit
for the fact that he's hung around you
know and and really beat the doubters
and he's had some good moments and
played some of his best football here at
the end of his career
i would say ryan fitzpatrick because
he's an underdog whereas yeah right
cutler we look at and we go and i
remember you loved cutler coming out of
college like right and you liked him
more than any of those quarterbacks i
believe right yeah remember that that
was one of my first proclamations i
think uh what was that when i was like a
weekly guest and i was down there in
tampa right and you were like so who do
you take matt leinart or vince young and
i was like neither you take jay cutler
right so i i do i remember that very
very clearly and i took some heat from
some of my texas friends that day when i
said that but uh cutler feels like an
underachiever where ryan fitzpatrick
feels like an overachiever agreed agreed
uh i'm with you there all the way all
right has mac jones earned the starting
job in new england tom curran was
gushing about this that cam's been out
mac jones has been in and has looked
very impressive
knowing bill belichick having spent some
time there could you imagine belichick
going with a rookie quarterback to start
week one i mean i i think before
training camp i would have erred on no
to that but like i think mac jones has
impressed so much and been so good
through training camp everything he does
on and off the field
that i do and the fact that they kind of
praise them you know praise him as well
i do
i don't think they're scared i don't i
think in the perfect world they'd
probably rather go with cam newton but i
mean i still can't believe what cam
newton did i don't know no other other
way to say it i'm shocked i mean his
career is hanging in the balance and to
make a mistake like that and do that
it's just unforgivable and as you know
and anybody knows it's the patriots
they're like psycho detailed and now you
got a guy where he's not vaccinated and
you're not sure if he can trust him and
then you got this other guy who's like a
robot and kind of like tom bradyish and
he continues just to get better and
better and been very impressive in the
preseason so yeah i think there's a
chance and if he balls out this weekend
dan and i don't know if cam will play or
not this weekend now but if matt goes
out there and plays phenomenal i would
not be shocked if they just pulled the
trigger and started the mack jones era
i know that your uh co-host mike florio
brought this up about the jags that
maybe they were waiting to name the
starting quarterback because maybe urban
meyer wanted to go with gardner minshew
because maybe he didn't like what he saw
with that offensive line for trevor
lawrence he has since named trevor
lawrence i i follow florio's philosophy
here i don't want to put
trevor lawrence out there and have him
become another andrew luck i want to
make sure that there is that i'm going
to protect him he might not make good
decisions i want him protected at all
cost
and that's what would be my big concern
uh yeah your thoughts on trevor lawrence
getting this started
yeah i'm i'm with you there i mean that
that is a concern it's something that we
talked about a lot on monday you know i
brought it up with floria and i was like
listen i don't think it's a real
competition here like yeah trevor is way
better than gardiner minchu i mean maybe
doesn't have quite the experience yet in
those things but the talent is that's
not comparable but uh you know so i
thought like maybe that's and he
listened to the the monday night crew
right they were kind of saying some
things like that and i thought oh okay
so this is more about getting the team
in the right place it really has nothing
to do with a true competition i
i think really ultimately urban meyer
hey i know he's adjusting to life in the
nfl and all those things but damn he's
still really smart understands football
and i think he'll play a certain way to
protect trevor lawrence you know i said
today on the show today the phrase i
used you said andrew luck i said don't
joe burrow trevor lawrence don't do that
don't have them drop back 45 times a
game and all we got to win even though
we know we're not going to be in the
playoffs we got to go for five and 11.
like who the hell cares if you're 5 and
11 or 3 and 13 right like save the
franchise and they didn't do that in
cincinnati and you know i heard the
other night too urban meyer talked to
joe burrow in the off season so that's
in his mind and i think he'll do the
right thing here and realize the big
picture and not fall into the trap of oh
we're losing i just got to let trevor
loose and let him try to carry the team
i i don't i think he's too smart to to
see the big picture there has john elway
whiffed on another quarterback
i don't know if he's whiffed i'm not
gonna say that yet about drew locke
there's some things i like he played
better towards the end of last year i
think you know when you take a few
things into account here vic fangio he's
a defensive head coach they usually air
on let's go with the safer quarterback
let's let's go with the quarterback
that's not going to mess it up for my
defense george payton the gm he came
from minnesota he was there when they
drafted teddy and i think ultimately you
know
drew locke i think scarred vic fangio a
little bit last year with some of the
bad decisions reckless throws things
like that to where teddy is the safe bet
you know i don't know if teddy can
maximize the talent of the offense quite
the way drew lock can
but i think you know i understand his
logic here with going with the proven
veteran who knows how to protect the
football and is not going to mess things
up early on in the year and kind of get
them behind the eight ball if that
doesn't go well then you bring the
flamethrower you know off the bench and
go okay we need you we need you to make
some plays and do those type of things
and lock has looked very good in the
preseason
it feels like every year we get mixed
opinions on preseason like don't read
too much into preseason and then we
ultimately read too much into preseason
how important is like a pre-season game
to a regular season game
how how different is it
at the quarterbacking position sure it's
a lot different i i think the biggest
thing it's just more
it's just it's uh elementary for for i
think some of the stars you know you're
not going to unveil some of your best
plays there's really no game planning
like hey this team does this so we're
going to attack them like that you're
kind of just like hey we got to go out
here and work on what we got to work on
and do that and you don't want to show
too much for the re you know and have
team to be ready in the regular season
the defense is the same way you know you
don't get to see a lot of exotic variety
type defenses in the preseason and then
it slowly starts to progress where
you're going to see a little bit more of
that this weekend so yeah you're right
you don't read too much into it but
there's certainly some things that you
can take from preseason to go oh that
team like let's say the miami dolphins
right i'll just use them as an example i
either what are they 2-0 in the
preseason i don't really care what their
record is i just look at them and go man
the way that team looks i like it they
got depth on the front line they got
depth in the front seven they got speed
at the right positions two was improved
so that gives me the inkling at least to
say like hey i'm not going to say
they're going to the playoffs but
they're going to be right in the thick
of things and you know are going in the
right direction is chris sims pro
football talk co-host former nfl
quarterback matthew stafford says hey i
want to play in big games
and i don't want to be playing at one
o'clock on a sunday well
how much of that is on matthew stafford
that like you didn't win a playoff game
like
we look at the quarterback and
you know you're supposed to elevate your
team
i know he didn't elevate his team well
no see i'll disagree a little bit there
i mean the fact that they were even in
the playoffs at some of those years they
were only there because of matt stafford
you know and again i think we've talked
about this before let's not forget
horrible call in the dallas playoff game
right with the past interference late or
whatever the damn penalty is that they
called there i can't remember the
specifics they were kind of in the lead
that was a controversial call you know
the other year they went to what seattle
in a wild card game one year and played
in the playoffs there receivers dropped
the ball i mean go back and watch it so
the team has failed him to a degree and
a lot of these years dan where i'll
always argue or defend where they were
maybe seven and nine or six and ten i
wanted to go
like they would be two and fourteen if
it wasn't for matthew stafford no
thousand yard rusher since what 2012 you
know no offensive line no namesake
defense a guy you can come up with in
the matthew stafford era other than sue
early on in his career to go oh wait
they did have one good defense a guy his
whole error there oh wait they did have
calvin johnson okay they've had three
people in like 10 years what would he do
what is he supposed to do with that so
i'm a defender of him but i'm i know i'm
going to be watching this year too
because it's going to be a big year he's
got at least some talent and a system
around him here uh that he should be
able to maybe shut some of the haters up
well i was on the bandwagon probably
before anybody saying if you're looking
for an mvp candidate this is this is the
guy
and but i wonder about that you know you
lose cam acres is sony michelle an
upgrade
no absolutely not he is not sony
michelle i mean i listen that that was a
it's a risky trade in in my opinion to a
degree you know first off he's a
first-round pick and new england's
trading them away right there's
something they don't they don't like
right and you know anything you know
rams pick up nikhil harry then i'm gonna
worry about that one yeah exactly right
but they're desperate you know because
you know like you're saying you know
it's their run game is important to
their success that's how that's really
what you know their offense is based
around that and then the bootlegs and
the play actions and the speed sweeps
all come off of that so they they i
think you know the one thing i always
give the rams credit for they push the
the chips in the middle of the pile
every year and go we're going for it
we're trying to win the super bowl we
don't care we're not going to eight or
eight and nine or it was nine and eight
or anything like that we are going for
it so uh but sony michelle i mean knee
issues anybody i've talked to in the nfl
thinks it's not going away there's a
real issue there uh but i would expect
them to sign another running back or two
here when cuts are made you know to
bolster that group altogether
if belichick is calling you and he wants
to trade you somebody
yeah right you better be like what well
we need to do extra homework than normal
because i will say this belichick is
really good at getting rid of players a
year early than a year left he may not
be great at drafting players uh
certainly in the first round or skill
position players but hey you know when
it's uh hey i got richard seymour you
interested uh hey i got uh jamie collins
you and i got lawyer malloy you
interested like you go yeah those are
big names and then all of a sudden hey
anybody interested in malcolm butler uh
yes yeah how did those things who was
the uh uh logan mankins remember that
yeah tom tom's mad his offensive lineman
got traded to uh tampa and all of a
sudden yeah we never heard of him right
yeah no i know bill's got a great feel
of getting that you know oh it's coming
to the end maybe he's got one more year
but it's it's about over and yeah he's a
step ahead of the game that way and
that's some of the toughest things to do
as a head coach because you know yeah
it's
to say what you want these coaches do
like their players there is a personal
aspect but his ability to cut the cord a
year early has of course made them
really really damn good for a long time
because of that so uh yeah i would be
weary of sony michelle and i'll
certainly be watching more likely to
disappoint
yeah cowboys
browns
i'm gonna go cowboys i gotta see it to
believe it with the cowboys first the
browns last year just kept going like
this and then this year they just made
their roster just keep going like this
and it's year two in the same system for
baker mayfield okay and you know
everything you hear odell beckham jr
looking really damn good i mean on paper
the browns roster is as impressive as
anybody in football so
i think between that you know stefanski
and baker have created a little culture
there they're pretty damn good on both
sides of the on the both sides of the
ball and dallas i just want to go one
i'm not sure dak is totally himself and
he hasn't played and now he's going to
go to tampa week one and just what carry
the team i don't i'm not sold they're
going to be able to run the ball i got
to see ezekiel elliott you know
everybody's talking about he's leaner
and quicker i want to go it doesn't look
good that his legs are half the size of
dak prescott and hbo hard knocks i don't
know i haven't seen running backs really
be that successful when their legs are
half the size of the quarterback so i
got to see that and then of course the
defense we know was a disaster last year
so i i'll pick the cowboys in that that
department oh gosh
yeah what no no
it's just the it's the cowboys i know
they get more attention than it feels
like all of the other teams combined
i i agree but no but it's just because
they're america's team in that popular
fan base right
it really is for the most part and
jerry's you know amazing at keeping them
in the news and relevant and doing
things like that but you're right yeah
it's uh it's amazing they do they get
too much attention they got a few stars
but yeah they got they got to have a
team and you know that's where you know
you look at it where the team i mean
there's some good things but everybody
talks about the talent chris because
it's the cowboys like man those
linebackers sean lee leighton vander and
i'm going
where are these guys i know jaylen smith
i mean he's a backup i know you know
they paid him all this money he's a
backup he's not even going to start on
their team this year i mean randy
gregory second round pick nev he's never
done crap for them you know they've had
some interesting
moves and decisions they've made taco
charlton right first round pick a few
years ago i mean damn he might not be in
the league this year so they've swung
and missed there too that have i think
really been a detriment to the building
of their football team uh so yeah it is
they're they're over hyped it is it's
just dak prescott amari cooper cd lam an
ezekiel elliott and we'll see where it
goes from there uh when do you make your
super bowl pick um probably next week on
my podcast i got to start
kind of formulating you know play off
teams and doing that how about who are
you not picking
who am i not picking hmm like you mean
that of like true play i mean first i'm
not picking chicago to go to the
playoffs or anything for next year
neither is anybody in chicago yeah right
dude
i like that music that's great um you
know i mean
i don't know who i'm not picking
that's a
seattle i'm not sure about i gotta see
seattle a little bit you know a little
off season drama
you know new offense offensive line hey
we'll see where that goes the other
thing i'll just say too is you know
let's the defense got better last year
but
underwhelming secondary other than
quandary diggs nobody up front that
you're worried about right geron reads
gone it's a lot of like young guys where
you're going oh they got potential but
is it going to come through so there'd
be a team that i look at yeah i i almost
on borderline like
some i have some thoughts to go man
seattle i think is a on the playoff
bubble in that in that division i think
the 49ers the rams will be good i
wouldn't be shocked to see them kind of
fighting for their life this year better
team
chargers rams who has more wins
the thing that scares me so much about
the rams is they're just so thin it is a
22-man team
and like two injuries they could totally
be derailed there
hmm
man who am i going to pick i'm still
going to go with the rams i'm going to
go with the proven commodity here and
mcvay and and raheem morris being the
defensive coordinator with matthew
stafford as that chargers team i mean
listen they're a team that i'm certainly
thinking about putting in the playoffs
but it is a new offensive coordinator i
still don't know why they really let
shane stykin go out the door with the
success they had with justin herbert and
him last year but joe lombardi of course
we know he's pretty damn good under uh
sean payton so i i just i guess that
there's some things there i want to see
can derwin james stay healthy can joey
bosa stay healthy so that's why i'll err
on the rams but certainly wouldn't be
shocked that the chargers were in the
playoffs too
great to talk to you chris thanks for
joining us as always we'll talk soon all
right man see you see you guys be good
chris sims pro football talk co-host
play of the day's up next